les nouvelles technologies et castes aux
planches j'explique c'est quelque chose
qui vous passionne vous aussi et n'est
ce pas et là attention parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a trouvé un truc inouï
exceptionnel du jamais vu à fileyeur
points comme slash pie ix srv c'est
l'abréviation de quoi merci
regardez ça on va faire un morceau de
dessins et ça va donner une vraie image
voilà en gros c'est un algorithme qui va
texture ise nos dessins gervais conteste
ça le blème c'est que je sais très bien
que mes dessins il m'a jamais la
reconnaître bien il va juste créé des
monstres j'ai donc appelé quelqu'un qui
a le crayon facile clients
di rollo capuche et oui vu venir c'est
un mec justement coup nous a ramené une
tablette on va pouvoir vraiment pas la
mienne qui n'est pas la tienne on va
pouvoir dessiner sur une table est donc
bon pour moi ça change rien mais plutôt
ça va t'aider je pense moi j'essaie me
de mu à la souris voilà c'est tenir mon
la balle je commence et après tu
complexe parce que tu arriveras pas à
faire aussi bien que moi ça c'est fort
possible aaa
donc avec des animaux avec des
chaussures et avec des sacs à main on va
commencer par les animaux oui je sais
mais c'est que les amis on aime les
animaux caisse à partie comment faire un
chat un chat qui dort c'est plus simple
chaque devant rien waouh
demain matin il est en boule oui il ya
un problème de proportion ah oui on
freine tout court ah merde voilà alors
qu'est ce qui va me faire avec wahaha
est ce que ça et on dirait presque
qu'ils sortent bien achats que tu
ajoutes qui est idiot mais si les
charges c'est une écharpe une écharpe ou
huile synthétique du coup on va faire le
chat le chat qui fait de tout profil
monsieur le choc finalement tu fais un
ami un visage du matin c'est vrai c'est
vrai un petit museau ah oui un petit
museau moi je sais pas ce que j'ai fait
mais vas-y mon boulot et on va lui faire
une petite bouche puisqu'il avait smile
le chalet content l'asim trouver un truc
on est d'accord c'est le site je faisais
preuve du monde
oui franchement what the fuck mondiale
et ses horreurs
incroyable bon on a fait le chat qui
pose on a fait une chaque profil on a
fait le chat et sharp qui nous restent
quoi le chat qui sont en tête 1 il ya
vraiment les pattes et camille les
aisselles ils ont leurs pattes comme ça
tu sais que ton d'une grenouille oui je
crois que j'ai vu une grenouille
franchement quoi faire un film d'horreur
avec tout ça jean talon des créatures
ont dit avant quand des dépôts c'est un
truc je pense qu'il est plus sage
après cette horreur de te laisser le
crayon fenua châkidor attal châkidor le
chat qui dort note déjà une texture il
ya des poils ce qui est finalement
symbole du chat ça qu on dirait un
gourdin
j'ai fait un petit mais pour qui au pire
au dessus tu peux dessiner un soleil par
exemple déposé parce que voilà
pasqualetti ce que je sais pas si tu as
créé avec ce soleil mais j'aurais loupé
un truc mon gars
dès lors il est moyen parfait oui la
[ __ ] il a fait un seigneur des anneaux
vient jour ça
il tapait vraiment seront du taf est
sommé par le cheikh lui même franchement
idée sachant que le voile sph pas sûr
c'est lui que je choisis mes intolérants
mais franchement ça a donné un chat un
chat qui saute
chaque et seaux d'eau je le fais tu peux
faire un shakira
est-ce que d'en faire son jeu bon plan
c'était ok process vous mais j'aimerais
ça va elle moi c'est ouf
non ça passait franchement mec ok c'est
pas des gars allez vas-y suivant et tu
veux pas faire un truc genre caire
d'avoir faire un jour un pingouin ce
n'est pas un animal qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire tu veux faire un aigle nazi fait
un aigle
sinon bah écoute ça fout la halle et
process
voilà c'est sans presque plus un pigeon
jolie oui un peu des dieux team à
l'europe sort de la flaque d'eau 5e à
oui je sais pas ce qu'on préfèrera les
os était fier d'insectes oh oui oh oui
les fnl
[Musique]
allez bien des grossesses à 0 c'est une
boule de sa phase un mec ça passe tout
est trop mignon non mais ça a été je
loue à la mecque reviendra pas sur les
animaux annoncé moment de faire plaisir
aux gens qui aiment la mode voilà ça va
pour mahdi dalé les chaussures ok je
commencerais c'est ce que tu veux une
chaussure j'ai tellement d'inspirer mois
on en est là voilà sa chaussure et fait
la semaine en dessous ni pas quoi faire
hôtel et ça a tout changé
en butte à la barre alain smith là on
est passé d'une couvert c'est celui de
serre croyable là c'est parfait c'est
vrai où j'aimais personne n'achète mais
c'est que j'allais dire ni au fait nous
rêver oui c'est l'art moment j'en ai
marre de faire une botte en caoutchouc
karaoké jean lamoot quand ils voyaient
quoi oui à la plaque d assise en petite
ombre regardent le petit tombale oh oui
alors ça ça non mais il va nous faire du
duvet mecs sur la boîte ok ok d'autant
que vous chantiez attentes risquent une
attention attention au mont design je
suis content que par contre la couleur
encore les bêta mais c'est quoi cette
couleur et si c'était tendance à une
époque les votants comme dans tous les
couloirs raciste si si si si je suis bon
c'est pas mal mais franchement c'est
aimer les animaux végétaux
allez on passe au 5ème à des jets de fer
arbeit ou fait qu il tente en fait c'est
ce que je fais là comme ça que je t'ai
fait le t-bag arrête les avantages de
youtube attendant le monsieur je te
faire des vagues
vas-y cheveux c'est vraiment gentil de
faire comme l'agro on peut être sûr d'un
truc c'est que ce sac n'existe pas c'est
le médine squeeze choqué
je me sentis dessinateur temps mais
qu'est-ce que je peux faire après ça
comme à l'oral du bac en grâce avec un
élève trop chaud ouais tu sais plus quoi
faire et si on faisait le sac à dos dora
l'exploratrice
il est ok
vas-y process attention on n'a pas
trouvé le sac de doha pour toi ma petite
chérie mentale ont vécu mais ça ça va
plaire à tes copains choquette a déjà
tenté un troisième animation coup de
poker mais il ya un truc entre moi et ce
site il se passe un truc qui m'a fait
des vies texture de vous fait si tu as à
ce studio japonais
du coup j'aimerais retenter ma chance
pour vas-y les animaux ont fait un duo
genre moi je fais la forme globale et
toi et moi je dirais roc évasion
[ __ ] c'est beau et ça c'est un
excellent jeu là comme ça c'est vraiment
de la chorale ecolab je fais
[ __ ] mais je me suis jamais dans vos
centres effet de faire les les rondes
c'est que j'ai fait à l'heure ça marche
bien l'aviron savoir aux paris allez y
monde pour remplir ses yeux en lycées
sont bloqués avait un truc aujourd'hui
leur état
non mais la haye et franchement savoir
mrnf un truc
franchement ça mal la gorge sa voiture
j'ai les cheveux pour finir sur un tour
de ville avait vraiment l'air de le
terminer sur un truc parfait et si on
fait un humain sur un vrai visage lors
réaliste d'humains seule chose sur les
hits en termine sur ça on termine sur
une chimère un chat un chat et un humain
attention messieurs dames ça va être
incroyable zimmerli ce
[Musique]
pas mal du tout
le coup on a créé un x-men morville
station fait ça change je donnerai deux
millions d'euros pour que je le veux
livrer sur 24 heures eh ben les abysses
et la fin de cette vidéo avec ineo sur
le truc affiner les meilleurs points
comme cela un pays x est servi mais
sinon n'hésitez pas à passer voir la
chaîne donnio bon normand ils voient
cette table est donc là il a fait de son
mieux surtout que c'est un logiciel de
merde seul logiciel c'est juste un truc
un truc est bas et c'était pas loin sa
chaîne et puis n'est-ce pas le dos à
vous a plu on a fait des chimères natale
tout du ouf on a un peu un feu design et
de la nouvelle mode au signalement au
niveau chaussures sales à coeur la terre
j merci on a attaché à bien
c'est une très belle conclusion merci
merci merci
[Musique]
ça